vincent bonsoir moi alors quelle est
cette question comme le thé noir au
canada dans quelle province est
installée une des premières communautés
noires au canada
la réponse c'est la nouvelle écosse le
plupart des canadiens savent
qu'aujourd'hui encore c'est en nouvelle
écosse qu'on retrouve l'une des plus
grandes communautés noires au canada où
une des plus anciennes à tout le moins
encore aujourd'hui qui se trouvent dans
les provinces maritimes du canada ya une
ville qu'il faut retenir
tu pourras faire la recherche peut-être
lorsque tuera dans une bibliothèque ça
s'appelle bridgetown birch town et c'est
devenu le plus important peuplement
d'africaines libre à l'extérieur de
l'afrique
là on est à la fin du xviiie siècle il
était d'origine africaine mais tu sais
il y en avait plusieurs qui était
d'origine américaine
c'était des esclaves noirs qui avaient
fui les états unis parce qu'à ce moment
là il y avait une guerre d'indépendance
aux états unis avait des gens aux états
unis qui était loyal à la couronne
britannique qui voulait toujours que la
couronne britannique gère tout le
territoire nord américain
ils s'opposaient à la guerre
d'indépendance des américains parmi eux
il y avait des noirs les experts noir
ont été invités par la couronne
britannique à venir au canada on leur
disait venez au canada nous allons vous
donner des terres on va vous donner vous
l'occasion donc de défricher en homme
libre
le canada mais il faut dire c'est pas
aussi rose qu'on leur raconte
parce que c'est la plupart des noirs qui
ont accepté ce marché des anglais ils
sont venus au canada n'ont pas ont été
parmi les derniers à recevoir des
lotissements terre on a invoqué des
problèmes de cadastre d'arpentage y
manquait d'arpenteur pour prendre les
mesures des terrains je sais pas s'ils
avaient une histoire de racisme derrière
ça c'est pas dit dans l'île dans les
livres que j'ai consultés mais ils ont
été les derniers à être servi à être
remercié par la couronne britannique
pour leur effort de guerre
oui on peut dire que la plupart de des
noirs américains qui sont venus
s'établir au canada étaient dix fugitifs
ou qui veulent fuir la guerre de
sécession américain
d'accord mais il ya beaucoup plus à dire
que ça je vais commencer par la première
personne d'origine africaine qui a mis
les pieds en sol canadien
toi tu connais tu as connu ont enseigné
à l'école l'histoire de l'exclavage
notamment c'est au niveau du bénin que
ça se pratiquait qu'on est chez les
africains pour tu vois je ne sais pas de
quelle origine
de quel pays contemporain venait ce
premier africain en sol canadien
il est arrivé il ya quelques 400 en son
nom c'était mathieu da costa est ce
qu'il ya des da costa au bénin et
c'était pas un esclave
c'était un homme libre et il a oui ils
avaient été amenés ici par apparemment
des religieux et il travaillait en tant
qu'interprète il servait de lien entre
un peuple amérindien qu'on appelle les
micmacs qui existe encore aujourd'hui et
les européens qui étaient sur le
territoire qui était qui arrivait là qui
venait colonisé le territoire mais ça on
donc au 1 504 en 528 malheureusement
arrivent l'esclavagé formellement au
canada et sa durée pendant plusieurs
années sa durée jusqu'en 1793
c'est au canada qu'on a pour la première
fois dans l' empire britannique le
canada appartenait l'envié britanniques
c'est au canada on a aboli
c'était le premier endroit au monde
faisant partie lambert britannique qu'on
a aboli l'esclavagé en 1793
on a attendu en 1893 pour l'abolir à
travers tout l'empiré britannique
le premier esclaves connu portait le nom
de olivier lejeune
il a été enregistré dans les registres
du gouvernement en 128 on l' année au
canada de l'afrique
il était tout jeune il avait à peine
même pas dix ans je ne savais pas tu
m'apprends quelque chose
[Musique]
est-ce que j'ai bien répondu à ta
question de façon générale oui mr
6 alors on se reparle une prochaine fois
d'accord merci à toi c'était vincent
tognon qui se trouve au bénin